hallo herzlich willkommen zur sail
israels heute packe ich eine richtig
leckere torte ich weiß ja wirklich alles
schon lange drauf gewartet heute ist in
dem sie zur torte an der reihe und zwar
habe ich eine richtig tolle torte für
euch kreiert ich habe hier unten einen
tollen mit dreck boden mit drin einen
haselnuss biscuit boden denn luca zahn
und das ganze habe ich dann auch
dekoriert mit toto kugeln und ich habe
jetzt nicht nur diese torte für euch
sondern ich habe insgesamt zehn rezepte
mit schotter für euch kreiert und diese
rezepte gibt es auch in den lotto
packungen die sind jetzt für kurze zeit
im handel erhältlich und da ist immer
eine von zehn rezepte mit dabei und am
ende dieses videos gibt's noch ein
richtig tolles gewinnspiel als ich habe
wirklich ganz tolle gewinn pakete zu
verlosen
da komme ich aber am ende noch mal
darauf zu sprechen und wir starten jetzt
direkt mit der torte und ich zeige euch
was ich an zutaten dafür benutze
zuerst muss ich die füllung zubereiten
denn ich möchte eine nuss nougat alle
machen und zeigt euch jetzt hier einmal
kurz die zutaten
ich habe 800 gramm sahne 400 gramm lukas
500 gramm mascarpone und acht teelöffel
sahne stand mittel und ich nehme jetzt
zuerst einmal die sahne und den nutzer
die anderen zutaten kann ich jetzt
erstmal weg stellen und die mascarpone
auch wieder kaltstellen
denn den lukas sahne muss jetzt dann
auch wieder abkühlen und dem muss dann
kurz aufkochen
und sobald die sahne koch dem es dann
einfach aufpassen dass ihr euch nicht
überkocht nehme ich sie vom herd
herunter und gibt genug masse dazu ganz
vorsichtig das nicht spritzt und jetzt
rührt ihr einfach so lange mit dem
schneebesen durch bis sich die nubert
maße gut aufgelöst hat und die
nutzerzahlen homogen ist
jetzt will ich die nutzerzahl um und
dann musste erstmal in den kühlschrank
gestellt werden damit sie auf
kühlschranktemperatur kommt und in der
zwischenzeit kann ich dann schon mal die
beiden böden vor backen als nächstes
bereite ich jetzt den mürbeteig da sitzt
der unter der torte das richtig schön
knusprig und dafür habe ich nur ganz
wenige zutaten
ich brauche 100 gramm mehl 50 gramm
zucker 70 gramm butter 50 gramm
haselnüsse und eine stange giotto und
jetzt nämlich zuerst die otto und
zerkleinert die kurz es geht am besten
mit einem mixer oder einfach in einen
gefrierbeutel füllen und dann mit
nudelholz
und jetzt kann ich einfach alle zutaten
mit der küchenmaschine kurz verkneten
ihr könnt es natürlich auch mit den
händen machen aber mit der
küchenmaschine oder dem handrührgerät
geht es eben schneller
alle zutaten zusammen ein und jetzt kurz
verrühren
jetzt gibt peter thome dazu und lass
alles zu einer schönen homogenen masse
verrühren
jetzt hat sich alles gut verbunden
und jetzt muss ich den teig aber noch
mal kurz kühl stellen und dafür form ich
ihnen jetzt mit den händen zu einer
kugel zusammen und gebe ihnen dann für
eine halbe stunde den kühlschrank und in
der zwischenzeit werden wir gleich vor
den biskuit vorbereiten
für den bis geht habe ich die zutaten
jetzt auch schon gerichtet ich brauche
dafür 75 gramm haselnüsse sieben eier
240 gramm zucker eine prise salz etwas
vanille extrakt 185 gramm mehl 80 gramm
speisestärke hier vorne habe ich einen
halben teelöffel backpulver und einen
halben teelöffel zimt und davor eine 75
gramm butter die habe ich bereits im
topf zerlassen
zuerst einmal nämlich jetzt die
haselnüsse die benutze ich immer ganz
gern im ganzen also auch vorhin bei
mürbeteig waren sie ganz und ich habe
sich selber fein gemahlen und zwar
deswegen weil sie dann einfach ein
schönes aroma haben also viel besser wie
die fertig gemahlen haselnüsse gebe ich
die hier in einen mixer rein und mal die
kurzweil
und damit dieses hafens aber noch
verstärkt wird
gebe ich die hasen ist jetzt in eine
pfanne ohne fett und rüste die da drin
einfach ist auf höchster stufe schalten
und trösten lassen und aufpassen dass
ihr euch nicht verbrennen
also ich schenk dir dann immer mal
wieder durch und in der zwischenzeit
kann ich schon vermisst wird anfangen
und zwar gebe ich dafür die eier in die
rührschüssel da kommt dann super mit
dazu dann auch die prise salz und das
vanille extrakt können natürlich auch
vanillezucker nehmen aber das hat
einfach ein besseres aroma und jetzt
müsst ihr diese eier zuckermasse richtig
lange rühren lassen also wirklich 15 bis
20 minuten bis sie schön schaumig wird
und krieg wird
die eier masse ist jetzt richtig schön
klingt schlüssig also richtig cremig wie
ihr sehen könnt und ihr müsst es auch
wirklich ganz lange röhren damit ihr
steht an den schönen biscuit habt jetzt
brauche ich die maschine nicht mehr und
kann die trockenen zutaten jetzt einmal
durch den sich geben damit keine
klümpchen habe und dann wird alles nur
noch unter gehoben
jetzt habe ich das vorsichtig unter der
bis geht darf halt nicht mehr zusammen
fallen und die haselnüsse sind jetzt
mittlerweile auch abgekühlt habe ich in
der pfanne gerüstet und irgendwann
einfach die pfanne ausgemacht also dem
herd ausgemacht und jetzt sind sie auch
abgekühlt
deswegen kann ich sie jetzt auch direkt
mit rein geben auch kurz unterheben und
es ist jetzt wirklich so ein richtig
aromatischer teig und jetzt noch die
flüssige butter dies auch mittlerweile
ganz kalt
und den teig fühle ich jetzt in eine
vorbereitete form und zwar habe ich den
bug rahmen auf 26 cm eingestellt ihr
könnt auch eine springform nehmen aber
im park kamen backen dewis geteilte
einfach etwas gleichmäßiger und ihr habt
auch eine kürzere bauzeit
deswegen fühle ich den bereits ryan und
streichen auch gleich wird
und so kommt dath eick jetzt bei 175
grad im vorgeheizten backofen ich mag
bei ober unterhitze für etwa 35 minuten
ich mache dann auf jeden fall mit dem
zahnstocher die stäbchen probe und
zeigen euch dann wenn er fertig ist
in der zwischenzeit ist auch der möglich
abgekühlt und stehen jetzt auch in einer
vorbereiteten springform oder in einem
waggon besser gesagt und rollt den da
jetzt gut aus wir können jetzt natürlich
auch warten bis der biscuit erst mal
gebacken ist in dem dann einfach danach
backen
ich pack das jetzt kurz in der
zwischenzeit dafür gebe ich den dreien
und entweder form der denn jetzt mit den
händen so klappt oder ihr nehmt einfach
einen ausdrucksstarken mit bisschen mehl
klebt es dann auch nicht an der hand
sind jetzt einfach in die form anpassen
und wenn der teig dann gleichmäßig
verteilt ist stelle ich hier noch mit
einer gabel ein
dann geht aber ein packen nicht auf und
bleibt einfach schön flach und ich kann
denn jetzt auch direkt so kalt wie er
ist im vorgeheizten ofen bei 190 grad
ober unterhitze für etwa neun minuten
backen
und dann warte ich einfach bis alles
scheint abgekühlt ist also mit whisky
teig und creme und dann geht es später
gleich weiter
die zwei blüten sind jetzt abgekühlt und
auch die nutzerzahl ist abgekühlt und
jetzt kann ich die torte zusammensetzen
ich muss jetzt zuerst die creme machen
und dafür gebe ich jetzt erstmal die
mascarpone in die rührschüssel und
verrührt kurz mascarpone ist immer so
ein bisschen fest und wenn man die
vorher nicht gut verrührt haben wir
später klümpchen in der sahne also erst
die mascarpone rein wenn sie zum
beispiel aber auch nicht zu lange ist
auf der insel
und jetzt lasse ich ganz langsam genug
astana meter zu laufen und dann wird es
ganz schön homogen
jetzt gebe ich noch die sonne stand
mittel dazu
und lass die kriegen dann steigt
die creme ist jetzt fest und jetzt kann
ich den tortenboden zerteilen und
wahrscheinlich den zweimal waagerecht
durch das klappt am besten mit einer
torten säge oder indem scharfes messer
aber so hart 23 gleichmäßige böten
jetzt kann ich die torte zusammensetzen
ich habe jetzt hier 100 gramm chilli ihr
könnt auch ein anderes stelle benutzen
und streicht es jetzt auf den mürbeteig
es bringt also ein bisschen frucht in
die torte
dann setze ich direkt den ersten blick
drauf
da kommt da der tortenring außenrum
damit die sahne schön
gestartet werden kann und jetzt fühle
ich ein drittel dieser sache rein dann
gut verstreichen
jetzt kommt der mittlere teil auf die
torte dann gut andrücken und jetzt das
zweite drittel
jetzt kommt der deckel drauf den auch
gut andrücken und jetzt noch der rest
oben drauf aber ein bisschen creme ist
er weg legen so etwa zehn esslöffel und
zwar brauchen wir den später für die
dekoration
jetzt hab ich die torte glatt gestrichen
und dexia ab jetzt kommt sie für
mindestens drei stunden in den
kühlschrank gerne auch über nacht und
die übrig gebliebene creme ist da jetzt
auch kühl stellen
und dann geht es später noch mal weiter
jetzt kann ich die torte fertig stellen
wie es richtig gut kalt und ich setze
jetzt erstmal auf wunderschöne
tortenplatte geht ja auch ganz gut weil
wir diesen festen hauptrunde haben jetzt
entferne ich den torten rahmen mit einem
paletten messe
und jetzt habe ich ja diese creme die
ich vorhin zurückgelegt habe und nehmen
die und streiche jetzt den rand der
torte noch schön glatt
die restliche creme fühle ich jetzt in
einen spritzbeutel mit einer stern töne
und kann damit dann die oberfläche der
torte verzieren
und damit ich das gleichmäßige tupfer
drauf bekommen nämlich einfach so ein
torten einteiler und teilt zwölf stücke
einigen natürlich auch 16 oder weniger
nehmen so kurz an drücken und dann kann
ich das nämlich jetzt die tube vertrag
setzen
und wenn ihr übrigens auch so eine
rutschige tortenplatte habt wie ich mir
jetzt eben auch was die torte
runtergerutscht müsste einfach ein
bisschen creme auf die trocken platte
tupfen dann klebt da auch dieser markt
gut drauf an
wer jetzt noch ein bisschen creme übrig
habt ist es nicht schlimm die könnte
einfach aufmachen verlassen
so jetzt habe ich hier noch ein bisschen
müsse und zwar habe ich 200 gramm
gehackte nüsse die habe ich jetzt vorhin
schon in der pfanne geröstet und
abkühlen lassen und mit denen verzichtet
noch den rand der torte
und jetzt kommt auch das schönste teil
jetzt immer nämlich gleich fertig jetzt
nämlich noch die lottokugeln und setzte
als dekoration oben drauf und dann
zimmer gleich fertig und können die
torte probieren
die torte ist jetzt fertig und ich kann
sie jetzt an schneiden dann seht ihr sie
auch von innen
die gibt es jetzt nämlich gleich bei uns
zur kaffeerunde mit unseren freunden
gibt's natürlich auch ein café mit dazu
und alles einfach ganz gut passt
und zwar gut wie sie aussieht so
schmeckte hat natürlich auch ne als
werden jetzt hier unten diesen
knusprigen mögen teig mit dem motto
kugeln dann die das case shiller also
richtig schön fruchtig darauf kommt der
lockere haselnuss biscuit und die lukas
sahne und ganz oben drauf eben noch mal
eine rote kugel und das rezept gibt es
auf meinem blog of this blog de oder in
den job verpackungen da habe ich auch
noch neun weitere rezepte für euch
kreiert das heißt zehn rezepte insgesamt
und die torte dürft ihr gerne nachmachen
ich wünsche euch auf jeden fall ganz
viel spaß dabei aber jetzt bleibt ihr
noch dran denn jetzt geht es noch zum
tollen gewinnspiel
ich hab jetzt zehn rezepte mit toto für
euch kreiert und jetzt seid ihr an der
reihe und zwar habt ihr die einmalige
chance eine von zehn maschinen oder 1
von 500 giotto back paketen zu gewinnen
jetzt müsst ihr folgendes tun
er kreiert jetzt auch ein motto rezept
lautet dieses rezept mit bild unter
dieser eingeblendeten adresse hoch und
die jogger jury und ich wir wählen dann
die besten rezepte aus unter
teilnahmeschluss der aktion ist der 30
sechster und ich wünsche euch jetzt ganz
viel kreativität für viele tolle rezepte
wünsche euch ganz viel spaß beim
nachbacken der die tatorte und wir sehen
uns das nächste mal wieder biss dann